ظهرت سلسلة من مقاطع الفيديو في بداية عام
2017 ،
تكشف عن أحد أكثر
حوادث الحرب إثارة للقلق في سوريا ،
وهو رجل أعزل سخر منه وعذب من قبل
أربعة رجال ناطقين بالروسية يرتدون زيا عسكريا ،
ثم قاموا بضربه
بقدميه ورجليه بشكل متكرر بمطرقة ثقيلة.
يرفعون
صرخات الألم التي غمرها
صوت الموسيقى العسكرية الروسية القومية وضحكهم في
وقت لاحق من ذلك العام وفي عام 2019
ظهرت المزيد من مقاطع الفيديو للحادث على الإنترنت ،
إنها رسومية للغاية بحيث لا تظهر
حتى تفاصيل مفزعة ،
يتناوب الرجال على تقطيع الأوصال و
بقطع رأس ضحيتهم التي يبدو أن كلماتها الأخيرة
هي تلاوة الشهادة ،
إعلان عن دين مسلم يتم
التحدث عنه عادةً كمعدل للوفاة ، تم التعرف على
سعادتهم الشاذة
خلال هذه المحنة التي حدثت
في غرفة التعذيب المؤقتة في الصحراء السورية ،
تم التعرف على أحد الرجال في عام 2019
قال التحقيق الذي نشرته الصحيفة الروسية المستقلة نوفايا غازيتا عن عضو مزعوم في كيان واغنر العسكري الروسي الخاص الغامض الذي له صلات بالكرملين الذي يعمل في سوريا إلى جانب القوات الروسية ، تم التعرف على الضحية على أنه محمد أحد الهاربين من الجيش السوري في موسكو عام 2019.
ليس لها علاقة بالعمليات العسكرية الروسية
في سوريا
وطلبات نوفو أغاسيتا إلى
هيئة التحقيق الرئيسية في البلاد لبدء
تحقيق تم رفضها
بعد أربع سنوات من القتل المروع
لجماعات حقوقية من روسيا
وفرنسا وسوريا التي رفعت دعوى قضائية
في موسكو في محاولة  فتح
تحقيق في الحادث ،
هذه هي المرة الأولى التي يحاول فيها أي شخص على الإطلاق
تحميل
أي عضو في فاغنر المسؤولية
عما تقول جماعات حقوق الإنسان
إنه جزء من قائمة متزايدة من
الفظائع المزعومة التي ارتكبها المرتزقة
مع وجود بصمة عالمية موسعة
تسمح لروسيا بالتقدم  خارج
كتب السياسة الخارجية ، تم
رفع القضية نيابة عن
شقيق الضحية الذي كسر
صمت عائلته في مقابلة حصرية مع شبكة CNN
مع سلامة العائلات التي لا تزال داخل
سوريا ،
يقول عبد الله إن محمد لم يشارك أبدًا
في الحرب لإعالة أسرته الشابة
التي كان يعمل بها.  كعامل بناء في
لبنان في
المرة الأخيرة التي سمع فيها عبد الله عنه ،
قال محمد إنه اعتقل من قبل
النظام في طريق عودته إلى سوريا
وأجبر على الانضمام إلى الجيش
لكنه خطط للهروب من
العائلة التي فقدت الاتصال بمحمد
لعدة أشهر
حتى  هذه
المرة
[موسيقى]
في البداية حصل عبد الله على مقطع فيديو التعذيب فقط
ولشهور تمسكت الأسرة
بالأمل في أن يكون محمد لا يزال على
قيد الحياة
سافر والده إلى دمشق وقام
بتفتيش المستشفيات والسجون بحثًا عن
وفاة ابنه محمد ولم يتم تأكيده إلا عندما تم التأكد من
البقية.  من
مقاطع الفيديو المروعة التي ظهرت على الإنترنت وهي مسترخية وهم
يدخنون السجائر التي التقطوها للصور
قبل إشعال النار في جسده
من [
موسيقى] أجنبية
في حرب حيث
مرت الفظائع الموثقة دون عقاب ، فإن
سعي عبد الله لتحقيق العدالة لن يكون
سهلاً
كيف يحصل أي شخص على العدالة من
مجهول الهوية
الزي الروسي الغامض غير الخاضع للمساءلة من قبل
أي
شخص غير موجود رسميًا.